Hello, everyone, and welcome
to lecture 5 of CME 296.
So we are officially entering
the second half of this class.
So we did a lot of hard
work during the first half.
We derived a tractable loss to
learn how to generate images.
So if you remember, the
first three lectures
was us looking from
different perspectives
to derive that loss.
And then something else we did,
which was, again, hard work,
was figuring out in which space
those images were living--
so how to represent images.
And so this second half is
going to be more practical.
And this lecture is
specifically going
to be about the architectures
behind the image-generation
models.
So before we start,
as usual, we're
going to recap what
we did the last times.
So as I mentioned, the
first three lectures
were around deriving a
tractable training loss
to learn how to generate images.
So what we want is to be
able to generate images
like the one that
is on the slides.
And we saw that a
common denominator is us
starting from those.
So we saw three perspectives.
The first one was
diffusion with DDPM.
So we saw that we were
corrupting a clean image.
And then we were learning
how to reconstruct it
by predicting the noise
that we had to remove.
And so we ended up with a loss
that was actually quite nice--
L2 loss on the noise.
Then in lecture 2, we saw
another perspective, which was,
let's figure out the regions
of high density of the data
distribution of interest.
And what we did was derive a
loss that is based on the score.
The score here is the
gradient of the logarithm
of the probability distribution.
And then the last one was
lecture 3, where we actually
said, OK, this
problem can actually
be framed as a
transport problem, where
we want to go from an initial
distribution, which is
the noise, to the target one.
And here we derive the loss
based on the velocity, a.k.a,
vector field, which
is again, very nice.
It can be expressed as
an L2 regression loss.
And in between, we have
this denoising process
that is similar in these three
paradigms but done differently.
And then in lecture 4 we
said, OK, up until that point,
we just assumed that we were
able to represent images,
the XTs, and we
said, OK, actually,
let's figure out a good
way to represent them
in a way that makes sense.
And what we said
was that we wanted
them to be represented
in a space that was not
too high in dimensionality.
So there was a space called
latent space, in which we want
our images to be represented.
And we want the representations
to be meaningful.
So what does meaningful mean?
It means having some
structure to the space,
because what we
want is our model
to have an easy time learning
this generation process.
And we focused on the VAE,
Variational Autoencoder,
which was structuring the latent
space by having some constraints
on how the distribution was
behaving over the latent space.
So we saw this KL
divergence term in the loss.
But then we said, OK, actually
the images were becoming blurry.
So then we looked at
a number of strategies
to combat the blurriness.
So we saw the adversarial loss.
We saw perceptual
loss and so on.
So we're happy.
Now we know how to
represent those images.
And we saw also that if we were
to condition our generation
process with the
condition, we also
had a method called
classifier free guidance that
allowed us to generate images by
emphasizing more on the prompts.
And we did that by
predicting twice the,
let's say, noise to remove
or velocity or score.
And with a guidance factor,
emphasize the generation process
more towards the prompt.
So here this can be
represented on the image.
And this is where we stopped.
And then, of course,
we had the midterm.
And today, what
we're going to do
is to focus on the architecture
behind the image-generation
model, which until now we
considered as being a black box.
So I want to give a disclaimer.
There are many
different architectures.
Our goal is not going
to just have a catalog
of every single one of them.
But what I hope this
lecture will provide
is at least an intuition as
to why certain components are
always being reused.
So if you walk away with just
an understanding of why things
are the way they
are, then I think
it's going to be a
good thing for us.
So let's first start
by what we want.
So what we want,
if you remember,
diffusion, score
matching, flow matching,
they had a few things as inputs.
So first, they had x t--
the noisy image or
the noisy latent
that you're trying to denoise.
You also had some indication
of the noise level
that's given by time step, t.
And you also have a condition.
Let's call it C, which
it can be a text prompt.
For instance, if
you want to generate
an image of a teddy
bear reading a book,
that can be your condition.
So these three elements
are your inputs
that goes through
your generation model.
And as an output, you want
to predict, let's say,
the velocity that will allow
you to then iteratively move
towards your desired
predicted image.
And the goal of
this whole lecture
is to focus on that
generation model.
So that's the model that
we're talking about.
But before we go
into that, I just
want to give a few slides notes.
So the first one
is the condition.
So I mentioned it can
be a piece of text.
In that case, such models are
called text to image models, T
to I. But you can also have a
text and an image as input--
so an image editing
problem, in which case
the model will be called a
TI to I model, Text Image
to Image Model.
So here make this
teddy bear dance along
with the image of
the teddy bear.
And then another thing is,
of course, the outputs.
I mentioned there
are several ways
to parameterize your generation.
You can either predict the
velocity or, of course,
the noise or the score.
All of this is roughly
the same thing.
But just for the
sake of consistency,
we're just going
to say that we're
going to predict the velocity
just because nowadays
most models do that.
So with that in mind, what
do we want our model to be?
So first we want our model
to be able to understand
the global structure of the
image that it wants to generate.
So that's one.
But we also wanted to understand
the nuances of the local details
so that it can also
generate crisp images.
And of course, we
want a model that
not only is able to
have x t and t as input,
but can also condition that
based on external signals.
And so here it can be
input text or input image.
And we want, of
course, that model
to be scalable because of
course, nowadays, we're
generating images of
very high resolution,
and we're also generating
videos, which we have not
seen so far, but you can think
of this as being also applicable
there.
So these are our wish lists.
And let's start
with the first model
by first thinking about how
humans look at an image.
So you see this
teddy bear image.
So you have an eye on the
right side of the slide.
So when you look at this
image, what you're doing
is focusing on a specific
part of the image
and skimming through that
image, scanning that image.
That's what we do as humans.
So one natural way of thinking
about how to build such a model
is to have this bias.
I will call it bias,
and I will justify it
why I say it that way.
We want to have
our model be biased
towards looking at the image in
the way we humans look at it.
I'm going to call that
bias, inductive bias.
Who has heard of
inductive bias by the way?
Yeah, a few people.
So we say that the model has an
inductive bias when we build it
in such a way that it
behaves in some way
that we think it should behave.
So in other words, here
we're going to say,
OK, we want our model to
take some image as input,
and scan it a little
bit like humans do.
And that's the
reason why I'm going
to introduce an operation
that maybe you're already
familiar with, which is called
the convolution operation, which
takes some inputs, let's
say an input image,
and then uses a filter
to perform convolution
operation across that
input in order to generate
or in order to
produce an output.
So just on the terminology
side, the output
is usually called feature
map or activation map.
And here this
convolution process
typically leads to your
output exhibiting things
like edges, corners,
texture, from your inputs.
So it's going to extract
features, visual features.
So another thing that I
will note is on this slide,
you may think the convolution
is done in a 2D manner,
but let's remember that images
are represented in height,
width, but also depth, because
you have the three values that
represent a pixel.
And so the filter is as deep--
if you want to think of it
that way-- as the input.
And so the convolution is really
across the depth axis as well.
So in particular, those
filters, they're 3D.
They have a dimension
of F times F times C,
which is the same C as
the number of channels
from the input.
And we typically
have K such filters.
And then the number
of steps by which
we move the filter
is called the stride.
So that's also a terminology
you should have in mind.
So based on that, let's
remember the conditions we had.
We want our image to
understand global structure.
We want to preserve
local details.
We want external signals.
And we want it to be scalable.
Well, with that, at least we
have seemingly a tractable way
of doing this computation.
So let's say that
number 4 is good.
Local details, I
think that's also
something that is
valid here, because you
are able to capture patterns
within a certain range of,
let's say, pixels.
So that one is also good.
But how about the
global structure?
You want your output-- so
here you want your output
to have seen the whole input
to be able to be aware of it.
So there is this concept
of a receptive field, which
is defined by the area
that an activation
element is able to see.
So here, let's suppose
we have an input that
has a series of convolutions.
So what we're saying
is if we take just one
element from the output, we
want to know how many elements
from the input it has seen.
So this is the receptive field.
So there is some
formulas there that I
don't want us to just
remember, but I just
want to call out that the
area that an element can see
is a function of the filter
dimension and the strides.
And if you want the output
to have seen all the input,
you can imagine that you
need a lot of convolutions,
because here in this
slide, if you do,
let's say, just one convolution,
then the area is just,
let's say, five.
So you do two
convolutions actually.
But images, they are typically
500 by 500, 1,000 by 1,000.
So you need a lot of
such convolutions,
which may not be as tractable.
So one idea that we can have is
to have down-sampling operations
that would allow us was to have
a bigger receptive field early
on so that we can have a global
understanding of the structure,
and then we can have some
up-sampling operations to then
end up with the same
dimensions as the input.
That's just an idea
I'm throwing out,
because let's remember
that our model needs
to have the inputs X--
so the noisy image as input.
And it needs to
return something that
is as the same dimension
as the input as well.
So you cannot just reduce the
dimension and just call it
a day.
You cannot do that.
So for that reason,
we're going to see
a series of operations
that are going to help us
in building such a model.
So here let's see a very
common down-sampling operation.
So who has heard
of pooling here?
Pooling?
Great.
So pooling, as you know, is you
take, let's say a given square,
and what you do is you
just down-sample it
by either taking the max value
or just the average value.
So there is no learnable
parameters there.
And speaking of
learnable parameters,
I may have been a bit too fast
there, but here the filters that
are used for convolutional
operation, they, of course,
are learnable.
And you have F times F times
C parameters per filter
plus some bias
term, if you assume
that there is bias, times K. Not
that I want to go to formulas,
but just giving you a
sense of what is learned
and what is not learned.
So pooling, you don't
learn anything--
just the pooling operation.
So this is just
down-sampling operations.
But I mentioned we want to
also be able to up-sample.
And there is an operation called
the transpose convolution that
we're not going to go
into too much detail,
but I just want to call out
that there is an up-sampling
operation, that is the transpose
convolution that uses filters
to broadcast elements from
the input towards the output--
so just up-samples it.
So given that, I hope it's not
coming out of the blue, that's
a model that
down-samples the input
and then up-samples it could
be a natural choice of such
a model, because here
what you're doing
is during the
down-sampling step,
you're able to have receptive
fields of your output
that sees most of the inputs,
which is the global structure
understanding part.
And then you have the
up-sampling part--
so the one on the right--
that just increases your output
once again back to the dimension
that it was just
in order for you
to have a shape that's
abides by what you want.
And here you can also
have direct connections
from one to the other to just
transport some local details
that you may have computed.
So such a model
is called U-Net--
well, because it's
a shape like a U
when you do the illustration.
And so I mentioned a little
bit of the intuition.
But we're going to
go step by step.
So the first step is
the down-sampling step.
So it has a combination of
convolutions and pooling
that are able to down-sample the
dimension of the feature map.
And as we saw, it just
allows your output
to have seen more and
more of the input.
And when I say
that, what I mean is
if you take a single pixel,
a single activation value,
it has seen more and
more of the input--
a bigger area of the input.
So in that sense,
what I'm saying is,
it is able to understand the
global structure of the inputs.
Is everyone clear
on that statement?
Cool.
So this is similar
to an encoder.
And then you have
the second step,
which is the up-sampling part.
So you have here a feature
map at the very beginning
of the up-sampling step,
which is very small.
And what you want is to
up-sample that feature map back
to the dimension of the input.
So here you're using a mix
of transpose convolution also
called up convolution
and convolutions.
And you can think of
this more as a decoder.
So it just leverages
the understanding,
the global structure
understanding
that is compressed
in the representation
at the very bottom, which
is called the bottleneck.
And it just gets it back to the
same dimension as the input.
But at that step, you
may tell me, well, sure,
you can have a global
understanding of the structure,
but you may lose the details.
And that's where these
connections come into play.
So during the down-sampling
step, what you want
is to leverage the patterns
that you're computing
in the up-sampling step.
So what you're doing is
you're taking at each level
a part of the feature map, and
you're just simply copying--
so cropping and copying.
So that just allows
local details
to flow from what
you have computed
in the down-sampling step
to the up-sampling step.
Is that part clear?
So the question is,
what are you copying?
What are you cropping?
So great question.
So what you're doing here
is the feature map that
you're computing in
the down-sampling step,
you're just literally
taking that--
literally doing that-- and
then the feature map that
is part of the
up-sampling step, you're
just concatenating
those features
to the features that are
in the up-sampling step.
So in other words, in the
up-sampling procedure,
you may have a feature
map that you're
computing that is let's say
of size O times O times C.
So what you're saying here is
you're concatenating something
that is also of size O
times O times C, where
maybe the C can be
different, but you're just
concatenating the two.
So of course, you have some
variations of how this is done,
but this is what this
illustration represents.
So the question is,
why are you not looking
at the down-sampled features?
Because we have already
lost the details already.
So if you see on
the slide, we're
actually copying and
cropping the features
that are before we're at that
very down-sampled outputs.
Because as you go down, you
lose more and more details,
but then you're gaining global
understanding of the inputs.
And so that's why you
want your connections
to go from the very top to
the other way and so on.
Yeah.
So the question is, how
we're training this model.
So we're training it jointly.
So we're not going to
go into details there,
but let's just assume you can
train the whole thing by just
considering it as just a model.
So the question is,
can the model output
exactly what the input image?
So that is not what
you want because-- so I
think you're maybe remembering
the autoencoder that we
saw last time.
So the goal of
the autoencoder is
to learn a representation
of the inputs and compress
it into in a latent
space so that you
can sample from the latent
space and then reconstruct it.
And the problem here is
you have the connections
that come from the thing that
you're not supposed to have.
So you can think of this
model as taking a noisy latent
as input.
But your goal is to not
reconstruct that output,
it's actually to
predict the thing that
will allow you to denoise it.
So in that sense, there
are some similarities
with an autoencoder,
but it's very different.
Yep.
So the question is, does
the output of the model
have to be equal to the
dimensions of the input?
Yes.
Because so the question is, why?
Well if you take your
input latent x t,
so if you remember back
in lecture 3, which
was like two or
three weeks ago, we
had the iterative
step, which was,
sorry xt plus dt is equal to
xt plus the velocity times dt.
So if you just look
at that equation,
you just see that the
dimensions need to match.
Another way to think about
it is in the diffusion
with the DPM formulation.
What you want is to find
the noise to remove,
and that noise needs to
match your input image.
Exactly, exactly.
OK, perfect.
I have a lot of content.
So we'll try to move
a little bit faster,
but I try to also
do some pauses here
and there to make sure
we're still together now.
So you have that model.
But now you may wonder,
well, how can you
add external conditions?
How can you inform your model
that you're at time step t?
that you want to condition it
with respect to some condition?
Well, that's a great question.
And so to answer that
question, you first
need to think about how you want
to represent your time step t
and your condition C.
Well, let's start
with the time step.
Here the goal is to represent
the time step in a D dimensional
space.
And before I tell
you how we do it,
I just want you to
look at your watch.
Well, as humans,
we construct time
as a function of
different dimensions--
hours, minutes, seconds,
days, and so on and so forth.
And you can think of
each of these dimensions
as being part of a vector
if you think about it.
And one thing that's
quite interesting
about these dimensions
is that they
run at different frequencies.
So for instance, an hour
is kind of slow to pass.
So I hope, by the way,
this lecture is fun
so you're not feeling like an
hour is low, but hour is slow.
Minute is faster.
Seconds are even faster.
So you have a difference
in frequencies,
a difference in frequencies,
which hopefully motivates
the fact that what we want is
to represent these time steps
as vectors of quantities
that are also sinusoidal--
so things that have
some frequency to it--
where some dimensions are,
let's say, slower than others.
So is that motivating example
intuitive enough for this
to be making sense?
So in other words,
let me tell you what
that illustration represents.
If you take a single
row, then what you have
is an illustration of the
values of each dimension.
So what that means is, for
instance, at the very bottom,
or let's start at the
very top, let's say.
You have values that alternate
between let's say 1 and 0
in this example.
And then as you
move down, you see
that some dimensions they
vary faster than others.
And this is exactly matching
the intuition I mentioned.
So that is for the time step.
Now the condition.
So I mentioned a condition
can be a piece of text.
Well, you have a number of
ways to represent that text.
We've seen some methods in the
past lecture in terms of how
to represent text and image.
But here, I'll just mention just
a few categories of methods.
So there's one where you have
very basic predefined class.
And what you're doing is
you're just learning the vector
representation of that class.
Or you can go more granular
and divide your input text
into tokens and then
have representation
for each of these tokens.
So for both these
categories of methods,
you have a bunch
of such methods.
But one very common
method these days
is just to get a
pre-trained LLM,
and just grab the
embeddings, which
we will not go into details here
but what people do nowadays.
And then for the
first method, we
can simply take
a VIT-based model
and just take the
representation of the CLS
token, which I believe we
briefly saw in the last lecture.
All of that to say that we have
ways to represent the condition.
Cool.
So let's suppose we have a
representation of the time step.
We have a representation
of the condition.
Now, how do you inject
it in your model?
Well, here again, you
have a number of methods.
There is no consensus.
One is injecting that
to the feature map.
So here what I mean is
you take your vector t,
you take your vector c,
let's say you add them,
and then you make sure that
the dimension of your vector
is, let's say, c the
number of channels.
And then what you do is you
add it to your feature map,
which if you remember
is of depth c.
So that can be one way.
Another way is to
modulate that feature.
And that part we will see
that in about 20 minutes.
So just wait for that.
And then the third one is you do
some cross attention operation
there, which we're going to see
as well, maybe in 40 minutes.
So all of that to say that
there are a number of ways
to inject TNC, and there
is not like a standard way
that people do it.
So this is just a
way for me to tell
you there are several methods.
So in terms of
timeline, we're in 2026.
So just giving you a sense
of when these models were
published when these were used.
So in 2015, the
U-Net paper came out
in the context of image
segmentation for, I believe,
medical images.
But it is something that has not
been widely in use in the image
generation field up
until the early 2020s.
So for instance, you
have the DDPM paper,
which if you
remember, we focused
on during lecture one
that actually used U-Net
as an architecture.
And then another thing
that's quite noteworthy
is latent diffusion model, which
was a paper that introduced
or that popularized the fact of
generating images in the latent
space, also used some
form of the U-Net.
And then we also had
a U-Net that was quite
scaled in a very big way
in Stable Diffusion, Excel,
which was published in 2023.
So if you look at that
timeline and if you
look at my explanations, you
may think, well, that's great.
We have everything.
Let's stop here.
We have our model.
Well, not so fast, because
in 2017 and in 2020,
there are papers that were
landmark papers that really
revolutionize, for
instance, transformer
revolutionized the NLP field?
And one question you may
wonder is, well, they're
performing so well there.
What about here?
What about us?
And that's what the
vision transformer
did in the image
understanding space, which
took a backbone
of the transformer
and applied it in the
image-understanding case
and saw great results.
And so now you may wonder,
OK, but can we do the same
for image-generation?
And that's what we're
going to see now.
But before we do
that, I told you
I will try to not give you
things out of the blue.
I'll try to build
some intuition.
And here, one thing I
want to try to tell you
is, why would such a model
be beneficial for us?
Because we have the global
structure understanding.
We have the local
details preserving.
We have everything.
Why would we need that?
Well, imagine if
you want to generate
an image of a teddy
bear next to a mirror.
Well, what happens
is in your image,
what you need is for
the low level texture
to be very similar in
one part of the image
and in a very different
part of that same image.
So the problem with the U-Net
is you have convolutions
that are localized to
in the neighborhood
in the vicinity of pixels.
But as you go further
from that pixel,
you have a bunch of
information that gets
mixed in whatever you compute.
So you don't have almost pixel
to pixel or patches of pixel
to patches of pixel interaction.
So you're not able to
cleanly capture or to cleanly
have an understanding of a local
detail in one part of the image
and local detail in
another part of the image.
And so this is a kind of example
that the U-Net may actually
fail.
And so for that
reason, the transformer
is actually a great
model for that because--
yeah, exactly.
So the transformer is
based on the concept
of attention, which was
initially introduced for texts.
I'm going to briefly mention
it here, but the idea for text
was you want to compute
representations of your words
as a function of
all other words.
So what you want is to have
direct links from one word
to another word,
regardless of the distance.
So what you have is a concept
of queries, keys, and values.
So what you're wondering
is, if you have a query,
if you have a text, you
want to know how relevant
or how similar all the
other pieces of text,
a.k.a tokens are.
So you want to see how the
query relates two keys.
And then once you how
relevant they are, so you
take some separation of
the two-- so let's say
dot product that's
normalized in a good way.
And then you can take
the associated value.
So that's the
attention mechanism
or the self-attention
mechanism that is aimed
at removing the inductive bias.
And here we can actually use
that same mechanism for images.
So you can think that you
take pieces of your image
and you're doing the same thing.
So you say, OK, a
given a set piece
of image, what are the other
pieces of the same image that
are relevant to that one?
So it's the same mechanism.
So what I told you also happens
to be very nicely represented
mathematically-- so very
tractable computationally
with the hardware
that we have today.
So you may have seen the formula
softmax of Q times K transpose
over some normalization
normalizing
constant times V. So that is the
self-attention operation just
in matrix form.
And on the right
side of the slide,
you have just the
transformer architecture
as it was initially introduced
in the context of I believe
it was translation--
so for instance,
English to French translation.
So you had two parts--
one on the left side, which
is called the encoder, which
computes rich embeddings of
your input, and the right side
is the decoder that allows you
to do translation one at a time,
by allowing each of your output
to interact to output that you
decoded so far, to interact
with the whole input.
So four images.
We're not translating
anything, we're just
processing pieces of images.
So we're only going
to borrow the encoder
part of the transformer--
so the left part.
And that's what we saw the
vision transformer did.
So it took just the encoder
part of the transformer,
and it took an
image as an input,
and it did something very
special to that image
as a pre-processing step.
So what it did was
cut it into patches,
and then consider
these patches as tokens
in the same way it
is done for words,
and then process them again with
the self-attention mechanism,
allowing each patch of image
to interact with all other ones
to just figure out which
ones are actually relevant.
So this was the DiT.
And let me introduce you to the
vision generation equivalent,
the diffusion transformer,
which it was introduced
in 2022, which is also relying
on the self-attention mechanism.
And we're going to
see exactly how.
But the idea is very similar.
You take a noisy latent as
input, and what you do is--
so remember the wish
list that we had.
We want to understand
global structure.
We want to preserve local
details and so on and so forth.
So here what we're saying is
we're just allowing all patches
to interact with one another.
Does that make sense so far?
It's not out of the blue
that I brought up this model.
No.
All good?
Perfect.
So let's go step by step into
what each component means here.
So you have on the illustration,
a patchy file operation,
that takes in your
noised latent and that
divides it into patches.
So you have let's say, I times
I times C tensor that you divide
into P times P times C patches.
And those patches you just want
to consider them as tokens.
And you end up with an input
length of I over P squared.
So the smaller your
patches, the higher
or the longer your
sequence, which
also matches your intuition.
So in that sense, you can
also tell from this step
that there is a trade off
between how granular you
want to be and how much
computation you want to compute.
So that's for that.
And then the second step
is to actually inject
your conditions-- so the
external signals, the time
step, and then the
input text, let's say.
So here what we do is we take
our timestep embedding, which
as we saw can be a series
of sinusoidal functions
that you have in
a vector, and then
your condition that can
be just an embedding.
So I believe in the
DiT paper, they just
consider the embedding of the
whole text-- so just one vector
for the whole text.
So let's suppose you have
these two quantities.
Now the question is, how do you
inject that into your model?
So the paper went through
different methods.
But there was one
that stood out.
So what we're going to do
is for me to just tell you
what methods they
tried out and then
focus on the one that
performed the best.
So the first method was
called adaptive layer norm,
which consisted of taking
the external signals
and then modulating the tokens.
So do you remember when I told
you modulating in the U-Net?
So that's the same modulating
modulation I'm talking about.
So that's the first method.
The second method is to say, OK,
you have your external signals.
What you can do is to have an
extra step in your transformer
block, where what you do is
letting the tokens representing
the image latents interact
with the time step interacts
with the label embedding
via cross-attention.
So here you can think of
it as you have queries
which are your noise latents.
And you're wondering which
ones of your conditions
are relevant for
your noise patch.
And then you do a
query times key,
let's say a dot
product of those,
and then you multiply by value.
So you express
your noise latents
as a function of
your conditions.
So this can be a second option.
And the third option is
to just say, OK, actually
we're going to
take these vectors,
and we're just
going to concatenate
that in the input sequence.
Very easy.
Well, it turns out that after
they did all these experiments,
they saw that the adaptive layer
norm was the most performant.
I'm going to give you
a preview of what we're
going to see in lecture 7,
which is how to quantify
how good an image is.
So there is a metric called
the Fréchet Inception Distance,
the FID, which is the one
that is represented here
where the lower that
metric, the better it is.
And what you see here is when
you use adaptive layer norm,
you get the bottom
curve that allows
you to get better quality
image quality compared
to the other ones as a
function of how far you
are in the training process.
So if you saw, there's
actually two versions
of the adaptive layer norm.
There is adaptive layer norm,
and there's adaptive layer norm
0.
I'm going to tell you
what that 0 is about.
But let's focus on
adaptive layer norm.
So I could very well
just give you the formula
and tell you that it
is adaptive layer norm.
But I think it's very
convenient to just build
an intuition as to
why it may make sense.
So I'm going to use
an example for that.
So I mentioned each patch can
be represented by a vector.
Let's assume that we can
interpret this vector
and say that let's
say a dimension is
responsible for something
and another one for something
else, which may not be true.
But for the sake
of this example,
let's suppose it is true.
So remember, we are
in the latent space,
and we can have some
semantic interpretation
of the dimensions.
So there is some truth
to what I'm saying.
But let's suppose you have a
vector where let's say the 10th
dimension represents the
intensity of, let's say,
the brown color.
Let's say dimension 24 is
how round the shape is.
Dimension 59 is how
fluffy the local details
are and then dimension 130,
which is how white the color is.
So let's suppose you
have such dimensions.
And now let's suppose
you want to generate
an image with the condition,
a brown fluffy teddy bear.
So you want to
generate that image.
And as you remember, generating
an image is not one shot.
Typically you do
that iteratively
where you take a noisy
latent as inputs.
And then you have the condition.
You have how noisy
that image is,
and you try to have something
as output that will allow
you to denoise your image.
And let's suppose that
we're at a stage where
there is a lot of noise.
So, the noise can be
represented on a scale that's
here we're going to
assume is between 0 and 1,
where 0 is super noisy.
1 is clean.
And let's assume that time here
is 0.1-- so a lot of noise.
So here what you would
want is to focus on-- so
at that stage of
the generation, you
want to focus on surfacing the
global structure of the image
because it's still super noisy.
You're just trying to sketch
what the final image is.
So here you want some
brownness in the image.
You want some round
shapes that may represent
your teddy bear and so on.
So you want these
features to surface.
So our intuition tells us
that you want these dimensions
to have a higher intensity.
In contrast to
that, you don't want
to have local details just
yet because it's very noisy.
So that's not the time.
And then you don't
want any white color
because your teddy
bear is brown.
It's not white.
Now let's suppose you have
the same condition as inputs,
but now you're at a
more advanced stage
in your generation process.
Now t equals 0.9, which
corresponds to almost no noise
in your input image.
So here you may
wonder, OK, so now
the input is already
quite figured out
in terms of global structure.
Now I need to focus
on the details.
So you want the, let's
say fluffy details,
to have a higher intensity.
And you don't want
the round shape
to be that intense because
it's already there.
And the brown color is same.
It's already there and
then white color again.
You don't want it.
So what I just
told you is how we
would like different dimensions
of the patch embedding
to have their
intensity modulated
as a function of the
condition, which is,
for instance, the input
text and the noise
level in which you are.
So in that sense, what you want
is for your patch embedding
to exhibit higher intensities
in the dimensions you care
and lower intensity in the
dimensions you don't care.
So in that sense,
what I propose is how
about we modulate these tokens?
How about we modulate
these vectors?
So here what we would do
is to take the condition
to take the time step as input
and to obtain some vectors.
So let's call them
alpha, gamma, and beta.
So let's assume we
obtain these vectors that
are a function of the
condition and the noise level.
And what we want to
do is to modulate
the embedding of the patch.
So how would we do that?
Well, you take your vector.
You do some normalization
just because it's not
part of the
modulation procedure,
but it's just good because it
just improves your training
stability.
So let's suppose you
normalize your vector.
And you do an element-wise
multiplication
with 1 plus gamma.
So if gamma is equal
to the vector 0,
the element-wise
multiplication of this and one
is completely [INAUDIBLE]
and nothing changes.
But if gamma is a
vector that tells you
that, OK, a given
dimension should be higher
and another dimension
should be lower,
then it will scale your x.
And by the way, I said
1, but it's the vector 1.
So you can think of it as a
vector matching the dimension
of gamma of just filled with 1.
So in that sense, you
can think of gamma
as being a scale
coefficient, a scale
vector because it scales x.
Then you can add
beta, which is a bias,
and perform some
operation, and have
an element-wise multiplication
of this whole quantity
with alpha.
And alpha will be your gate.
Because what you do
is you take your x.
You flow the same x.
And what you do is you make
some operation with that x,
and you scale it.
You shift it, and you
gate it with alpha.
And alpha is there to
tell you how much of that
change is going to
flow in your embedding.
So in that sense, I'm just
going to, again, stress
that these stars are
element-wise multiplications.
And alpha, gamma, and beta
have very specific roles.
So alpha really gate
keeps this whole quantity
from being injected.
Gamma is responsible for
scaling the quantity.
And then beta is
there to shift it
because it's a plus
with that quantity.
And do you remember
I told you I'm
going to say what
adaptive layer norm 0 is?
Do you remember in the chart?
Well, adaptive layer norm
0 is adaptive layer norm
where when you
start training, you
initialize your gates to 0, such
that there is no modification.
So by the way you, you set
alpha and gamma and beta to 0,
I believe in most
implementations,
but alpha being to
0 already guarantees
that at the very beginning
of training, you--
yeah.
So the question
is unconditional.
Yes.
So at the very
beginning, you don't
have any impact from the
condition on your embedding.
So far so good?
So we will have a detailed
example after that.
So I hope it will be
also clearer there.
But that is the
high level intuition
behind why adaptive
LayerNorm is useful.
It is there to highlight
dimensions that are
important for the task at hand.
And so here what we do is-- so
just recapping what we said.
We take our condition.
So it's the time step.
It's the class
label-- so t and c.
We add them
together, and then we
use just a multi-layer
perceptron, which is just
a linear projection,
some activation,
and another linear projection,
to obtain this gate, scale,
and shift alpha,
gamma and beta, that
are then used to modulate
the patch embeddings.
So the question is,
is t corresponding
to the diffusion time step?
Yes.
So it's how noisy you are
in your generation process.
So one example is in the
very, very beginning.
If let's say, your
input is super noisy,
then t is going to be very
close to 0, for instance.
But you will represent that by
your vector that is composed
of sinusoidal functions.
Yeah, that's right.
So the question is, is
this a reverse process?
Well, actually even
during training,
you would just inject the t
that corresponds to the noise
level of your image.
So we're going to see
exactly an example of this.
So I'll actually
answer your question
in great detail in a second.
Perfect.
Well, with that, what I
propose is we wrap up this,
and I walk you through
an end to end example
of what that looks like.
So your patch embeddings, you
run them through your diffusion
transformer blocks.
There can be several of them.
And at the very end, you
obtain encoded tokens-- so
patch-embedding tokens that
are aware of one another
because they went through
all these operations.
And remember what
we want is to have
an output that is of the
same shape as the input.
And so here the step is to
reshape that output in the shape
that matters to you.
Well, the authors of DiT applied
this to the DDP end use case,
and they actually assumed that
they were not just predicting
the mean but also the
covariance matrix.
So that's not very
common by the way.
So you would more predict
the mean but not both.
But I'm saying this
because that just explains
why there are two outputs.
But in our case, we would
just have one output--
in our case, the
velocity, which should be
in the same shape as the input.
And what the authors saw
was that if you take the DiT
architecture and if
you scale it in terms
of number of
parameters, then you
get better and better results.
And they scaled it in terms
of number of parameters,
but they also scaled it
in terms of how granular
the patches were, because the
patches they have dimension
p times p times c.
And if you take big patches,
then you have a much coarser
view than let's say, a
small patch, small p.
The problem with the
number of parameters
is it does not convey
that dimension.
So you can have the same
number of parameters
but vary p, which is why
the authors also use FLOPs.
So who has heard
of FLOPs before?
Floating Point
Operations is just
a measure of how many
operations you're
doing in your forward pass.
And that actually includes patch
size, because if you remember,
your input has a length
of I over P squared.
So if you have a smaller p,
you have a bigger sequence,
which is reflected in
your flops measure.
And in particular, so
that's pretty interesting.
So you should not only
scale one and not the other.
So they see that if they
scale the transformer size,
they get better
results but not great.
Now, if they only
scale the patch size,
they get better
results but not great.
But if they scale both the
transformer size and the patch
size, then they get
amazing results.
That's what you see in
the figure on the right
and also the chart
that tells you this
as a function of FID,
which as I mentioned,
is a metric we will
see in two lectures,
where the lower the
value, the better it is.
And that was the DiT.
Given that the DiT is a pretty
important architecture, what
we will do is take
our time to go
through an end to end example
of exactly how that works.
So our goal is to take an
input-- so here, the input text,
generate an image of a
teddy bear that is reading,
and what we want as an
output is the image itself
or the generated
image, I should say.
So in lecture 4, we saw that
we have a lot of incentive
to do all of this
in the latent space,
because it's more
tractable computationally,
and it's just
easier for a model.
So what we'll do is
we'll take a look
at the latent space learned by
a VAE that is at our disposal.
And you see you have
two distributions.
You have on the bottom left,
the initial distribution, which
is very easy to sample from, and
the target distribution, which
is the one that you
want to sample from.
So what you do is you sample
from your easy distribution,
typically your Gaussian
distribution in your latent
space.
Let's call it z 0.
And you obtain this thing--
dimension I times I times C.
What you do is you
take that image,
and you divide it into patches.
So each element has a
dimension of p times p times c.
So if you do some
counting, you will
see that I squared
over p squared patches.
And this is the length
of your sequence.
So you take each patch, and
you want to represent them
with a vector.
So you just perform
a linear projection.
And you obtain a
vector of, let's say,
dimension D. Great
for the patches.
Now let's take care
of the conditions.
So you have the
timestamp embedding,
and then you have the label
embedding corresponding
to let's say the teddy bear.
And what you do is super simple.
You just add them.
Add them together.
And you obtain your
condition embedding.
So far so good?
So here we are with
our patchified input,
where each element is
represented with an embedding.
There's something I
have not told you about.
And it's actually
something that Shervine
will cover in great detail
in hopefully 20 minutes.
When you perform this
self-attention operations,
the great thing is you let
everyone interact with everyone,
but then you lose the concept of
how far different elements are
just because you have
direct links, which
is why you need to specify in
which position each input is.
You need to have
a way to do that.
And here a very
naive approach is
to just add some embedding
that represents the position.
This is not the norm nowadays.
Shervine will go
deeper in there,
but let's assume here that
we add a position embedding
to the patch embedding.
And here we obtain a
position-aware patch embedding.
And we do the same for all
the patches in our input.
And nowadays, GPUs
they love matrices.
So we just put everything
in a matrix format.
So here we concatenate
everything.
And we also have our
conditioned embedding vector.
Well, let's start with that.
So I mentioned that the
diffusion transformer, so one
method of injecting
the conditions
is to modulate the patch
embeddings with the conditions.
So a first step here is to
obtain the gate, the scale,
and the shift coefficients
corresponding to that condition.
So let's do that here.
We input this embedding
through an MLP layer, which
is a projection
and an activation
function to introduce
nonlinearities, and then
another projection.
And we obtain six quantities--
two for gate, two for
scale, two for shifts.
So why two?
Because we will have two
operations in the diffusion
transformer block.
One is the
self-attention operation.
The other one is the
feed-forward neural network.
And we want these quantities
to be respectively
to go to their own operation.
So let's go back to our position
where patch-embedding matrix.
We input that into our block.
So what we do is we perform a
layer normalization operation.
And right after that, we
use gamma 1 and beta 1
to scale and shift them.
We input them to the
self-attention layer,
and then we get the
result with alpha 1,
which we add to the input.
So this is becoming very
complicated on the slide.
So I'm just going to
represent this operation
with just self-attention
and then alpha
1, gamma 1, and beta 1.
And as you remember,
this is what happens.
So you take your
input, and then you
do the attention operation with
the scaled and shifted inputs.
And you get it by alpha 1, where
the star operation here is just
the element-wise operation.
You do the same thing for the
feed forward neural network,
along with the alpha 2,
gamma 2, beta 2 coefficients.
And you obtain an output matrix
that takes into consideration
all other patch embeddings.
So it's something that went
through this self-attention
computation.
So that's why I'm saying
it's contextualized
because it's in the context
of the other patch embeddings.
But now what you want is
to have a prediction that
matches the input shape.
So what you do is you
perform some normalization,
some linear operation
reshaping in order
to have your
prediction, which is
the predicted
velocity of your input
z at time t with condition c.
In the very beginning,
z is z, 0, t is 0,
c is, well, just
your class label.
Just I want an image of a teddy
bear that is reading a book.
So you have this.
So just recapping
exactly what I said.
So we have the latent z, 0.
We have the time
step t equals 0.
We have the class label all fed
into this diffusion transformer.
And at the end of it, we get
the predicted velocity at z,
0 time t equals 0
and class label C.
And that's great.
But we're not done here.
We're only done here for
the iteration that allows us
to go to step 0 plus delta t.
And we perform-- so the
formula that I wrote
is just a reference
to the formula
that we derived in
the flow-matching case
where you're just
numerically solving.
So here's an Euler
solver that just
allows you to go from initial
to target by just following
the vector field.
So that's exactly
what you're doing.
So you obtain this
z 0 plus delta t
that you can also
have represented
like this on the left
in your latent space.
So that's great.
So now let's do one more.
You're at time step t i.
So you input your latent z t
i, along with the time step t i
and the condition
c that is not--
or the class label c
that is not changing--
so your input text.
So you put that in the
diffusion transformer.
Again, you get a predicted
velocity for that latent z
t i for that time step t i
and for the class label c.
And you go through
the same thing.
So you have the prediction.
And you obtain z t
i plus 1 by, again,
following the Euler method.
So here on the left side,
you have the next step.
You continue again and again
and again and again and again up
until z 1.
So now you're at t equal 1.
You have z 1.
That's great.
Well, what do you have?
Well, no.
It's not noise.
It's just it's the latent space.
So from a human perspective,
you don't know what that is.
So that's why I represent
it with the noise image.
But it is actually
your final latent.
And so the last step is to
take the final latent Z1
and pass it through
your VA decoder,
because you want to go
back to the pixel space,
because we humans,
we understand pixels.
We don't understand the
latent, or at least not yet.
And we get the
pixel space image,
which is the image of your
teddy bear reading a book.
And that's great.
And you will tell me,
Afshine, that's great.
We solved it.
Well, the truth is, these
days people are actually
using a variation
of the diffusion
transformer for a
number of reasons
that we're going to see now.
And again, I just want to repeat
one thing I said earlier, which
is there is a number, infinite
number of architectures
out there, infinite number
of variations, combinations.
My hope is to just motivate
why some elements that we're
going to see are being
reused actively these days,
but they're by no
means exhaustive.
So let's go back to the example
that we had with respect to us
wanting to modulate
patch embeddings.
So do you remember
the example we
used where we said we want
a brown fluffy teddy bear
and we had all these dimensions?
And we said, let's
say at t equals 0.1,
we wanted brown color and
round shape to be highlighted
but not the other ones.
Do you remember that?
So let's suppose now
I'm changing the class
label or the condition,
the text input,
to brown fluffy teddy bear
surrounded by white walls.
So imagine I do that.
Then the white
color dimension, you
would want to also have
it emphasized because you
have white in your input.
But remember that
this modulation
is happening for all tokens,
regardless of where they are.
So in other words,
what we're saying
is if you want to predict the
velocity to denoise an image,
you're going to modulate
all patch embeddings
in the same way.
But here what you want is for
places where you have a Teddy
bear to have Brown
that's increased
but not the white
color and for places
where there is the
white wall to have
white increase but not brown.
Well, you cannot do
that with the DiT,
and that's a big limitation,
which is the reason why we want
to change a little
bit our approach.
So that's great.
We're having the
self-attention mechanism there.
It's amazing.
The only thing we want to
do is to change the way
we're injecting conditions.
So modulating with
respect to the time step,
I think we can all
agree that makes sense
because all tokens
of your input,
they're all at the
same time step.
So it's very fair to
have the same treatment.
But we need to do
something else when
it comes to injecting the
text input from the user.
We don't want to apply the
same treatment to all tokens.
So out there, there
are two main classes
of methods that allows us
to introduce some nuance
to the way we do that.
And while there is no standard
classification out there,
I'm just telling you there is
two main classes of methods
that seem to emerge--
one that involves
cross-attention and one
that involves joint attention.
So before we go
further, I just want
to explicit a little bit more
what these two correspond to.
So cross-attention is the idea
of having something as input--
so your queries, your
patch embeddings--
and wondering how relevant your
keys and values, which here is
your text, is to your queries.
So in other words, I'm
going to use an analogy,
and I hope it's something
that will be intuitive to you
as well.
So let's suppose you
have a painter that
paints the final
image and then let's
say a poet that writes
the instruction in a very
eloquent way.
So it's the same
thing as saying,
if we were to say that the
painter, the one who determines
what changes to
bring to the image,
is actually looking at
a piece of text that
is brought by the writer, and
just based on that determines
what to change on the image.
So it pays attention to the
input text for a given patch.
It says, OK, what
is the piece of text
that is relevant to that?
And then based on
that it says, OK, I
need to change
this, change that.
So that is cross-attention.
So now what is joint attention?
Joint attention is saying, you
are considering your image patch
embeddings as inputs, but you're
also considering your text
embeddings as input as well.
And what you're saying is
that both these modalities
are being attended, if you
want, through the self-attention
layer.
So continuing the analogy, so
let's say, sorry, I'm a painter.
And let's say
Shervine is a poet.
So instead of
Shervine writing to me
exactly what needs to be
drawn, now, both Shervine and I
are in the same room,
and we're talking
about how things should be
placed with respect to the text.
And let's suppose
if I paint something
and then, I don't
know, I need to write
Stanford top right and then
my drawing is in such a way
that there is not
that much space,
then we can talk amongst
one another to say,
OK, actually, I want Stanford
to be written in maybe smaller
fonts so we can change what we
are each saying as a constraint
and doing as an image, as
a function of one another.
So in other words,
cross-attention
is considering text
more as being a given.
So it's OK.
So you have a patch embedding.
Look at which piece of
text is relevant for you,
and just do something.
And joint attention
is saying, OK,
let's consider both, and try to
find a representation of each,
such that we can get to our
final destination in the best
way possible.
So I hope this makes sense.
All of that to say that
nowadays most people do
joint attention-related
methods, and in particular, I'm
going to introduce a
term in one second.
But before I do that, it's
exactly what I mentioned
here-- the joint attention.
We're considering the patch
embeddings and the text
embeddings all jointly that goes
through this attention layer
and so on.
And the name of
such an architecture
was coined as being an MM-DiT.
So I don't exactly know
how you would pronounce it,
but I just go by MM-DiT--
so Multi-Modal Diffusion
Transformer.
And this term was
coined in a paper
that's actually not that long
ago-- so Stable Diffusion 3.
That was published two
years ago-- so in 2024.
And this relies on
a joint attention
of different modalities.
Now, there is another dimension
that some papers play around
with, which is whether you
want to consider each modality
separately or jointly.
And in particular, you know
in the diffusion transformer
architecture, you have this
feed-forward neural network
where you project.
You do some activation
function, and you project again
where you learn different
ways to just represent
the same thing.
And if you were to consider
all modalities as going
through the same thing--
so just continuing the analogy
of the writer and the poet,
it would be as if
you were saying
that both the poet
and the-- sorry,
both the poet and the painter,
they use the same tools.
So you learn the
same projections.
But if you were to consider
each modality on their own,
if you were to consider
specific projection,
depending on which
modality you're on,
you're actually
learning tools that
are tailored to the task
of whoever's doing it.
So the painter will
have a great brush
that is tailored to
whatever they're doing,
and the poet will have
exactly whatever is tailored
to their needs.
Maybe I'm pushing it too
far with this analogy,
but all of that to say that
we have two different classes
of MM-DiT.
One is single stream.
So everything is
treated equally.
And the second one
is double stream.
Each modality has
its own stream.
And you even have papers
that mixes the two.
So I call them hybrids here.
So they contain both single
stream and double stream layers.
And the next few slides are just
about calling out such models.
So the state of the art models
that you would see nowadays,
they actually are relying
on this architecture.
So I'm going to just mention
a double stream MM-DiT.
So this one is an
image for those of you
who have heard of it.
Then you have Z-image, as an
example of a single stream--
so here treating
everything as one.
And then for those of
you who have heard of it,
flux one contexts is
actually doing a bit of both.
So I put all the
links in the slides.
So we don't have time to talk
about each of these papers.
But if you're interested,
you can just go there
and just look at the papers
to see how they design it.
It is not in the
scope of the finals,
so don't worry if
you don't go there.
It's not required.
But if you're interested,
I think it's a good source.
And just continuing
the timeline.
So nowadays,
image-generation models
are full of MM-DiT-based models.
And in particular, if you
think about when the diffusion
transformer was published,
which was in 2022,
Stable Diffusion 3, which was
the first one to coin MM-DiT
was released in 2024.
And then the models I mentioned
were released in 2025.
And again, the ones that
are being published in 2026,
they seem to follow
the same trend.
All of that to say that I
think these are relevant
architectures that I think
are good to have in mind.
I'm looking at the time.
I'm slightly over time,
but any questions on that?
We're all good?
Perfect.
So with that, I'm going
to give it to Shervine.
Thank you, Afshine.
So with all these
models, we have
seen that one constant is
that we need to represent
the position of the input.
So the next section here
is called optimization.
But we're not going to look at
optimizations of everything--
just the optimization
of the position.
So in order to
make things simple,
I'm going to start
in the 1D case.
And then we're going to see
how we can adapt this concept
of positions in the 2D one.
So as you recall, the
original transformer
was based on text tokens.
So in this case, where
you have the sentence,
a teddy bear is
reading, what you
would want is when you do
comparisons between your tokens
in the attention layer,
that the token teddy
bear or the representation of it
is seen as being close to tokens
around it or itself and far from
others that are far from it.
That's the goal.
So let's write that
in mathematical form.
So what we want is a way for
us to compare two embeddings
and when you do an operation
like the dot product
to have it as a function
of the distance.
But here I'm saying
the dot product
of embeddings of these
tokens it's not totally true.
Here I'm going to
put it in quotes,
because in the
case of attention,
we're not comparing
the same embeddings.
We're comparing
the query embedding
with the key embedding
of the other token.
So it's modulo some
transformation.
And just to write
things down, we
are going to decompose,
as a first approach,
the representation of the
embedding of a given token
with what we call the input
embedding, which is whatever
representation we already have
that is not position-specific,
and then adding it as
an element-wise addition
in the vector space,
the position embedding.
That's what the original
transformer paper proposed,
such that when you do the dot
product operation that I just
mentioned, you have
a term that pops out
that is a dot product of these
position embeddings together.
And I'm not saying that all the
other terms are not functions
of this position embeddings.
Some of them are cross
terms, but we're just
going to ignore them for now.
And we're going to focus on what
choice to get for these position
embeddings in order for the
representation to make sense.
So the original transformer
hard coded it with a formula
that I just wrote down here.
So it might look scary.
Some of you might know about it
already, but for all the others,
it might look scary.
So you have a combination
of sines and cosines
that you might ask
yourself, why are they here?
So we're going to decompose
all the notations in there
and see intuitively
what they are for.
So you see that you have
the position as a numerator
within these sines and cosines.
And on the denominator,
you have some huge number
put at some exponent.
And that exponent is a function
of the position in the vector
and the dimension
of the embedding
altogether, such
that when you vary
this I between the first
and the middle position,
you cover exponents from 0 to 1.
So in other words,
you have these signs
that have frequencies
that are either high
when this I is close
to 0 because you
have the position over
something that is small.
So it's going to
vary quite fast.
So we're going to call
them high frequency.
And on the other
end of the spectrum,
when you have I close to the
dimension of the vector over 2,
it's going to be close to 1.
And as you can see,
the number that
is elevated to that
exponent is some number
that looks arbitrary,
but it's quite large.
It's voluntarily taken
quite large with respect
to the sequence length,
because the mindset behind it
is that we want these
frequencies when I is high,
to be considered as low.
So in other words, when you have
a sequence length of let's say
500, we want these 1 over
10,000 to be so small that
the variation of that sine and
cosine is of low frequency with
respect to the sequence length.
Does that make sense?
OK.
Awesome.
So now I'm going to show
you the exact same figure
that Afshine showed
in a different context
in a timestep embedding.
But it turns out
that here we choose
a similar mathematical framing.
So the same graph applies.
And we're going to analyze
parts of these projection
and then see how it compares
with respect to our frequencies
that we qualified
as high and low.
So on the left, we're
looking at dimensions that
are early on in the vector.
So we call them the
high frequencies.
And as you can see, when you
vary the sequence position,
these numbers, they vary between
negative 1 and 1 quite fast.
And on the other end
of the spectrum, when
you look at positions
of this vector
that are larger than the cosine
and sines take time in order
to cover the whole face.
So now I talked about a given
frequency that was hard coded.
This is a design choice.
We're going to hide
it under some variable
that I'm going to call omega y.
And we're going to look side
by side what these vectors look
like when you take position
m on one hand and position n.
And we're going
to try to see what
taking the dot products
between both of them
is going to give us.
So here you see that you have
these sines that are aligned
and these cosines, so that
when you do the dot product,
you have a sum of these sines of
similar frequencies at position
m and n and plus a product of
cosines of a same frequency
at positions m and n again.
And if you recall your
trigonometry class,
sine A, sine B, plus cosine
A cosine B is an identity.
And you can rewrite it as
cosine of A minus B, such
that when you compute
this dot product,
this is nothing else as the sum
of about dimension of embeddings
over 2 terms of this cosine
of difference of terms.
So it's quite interpretable.
So now let's take a look at
when we compare positions
m and n what the dot product
evolves with respect to time.
So you see that it has
this natural curve that
overall decreases.
But it's not monotonic.
It doesn't
monotonically decrease,
but it tends to decrease.
And you can see multiple
regions in this curve
that you can interpret
as to why you
have such phenomenon happening.
So at the very beginning,
you see a sudden drop.
And this can be
interpreted by the fact
that all your
cosines in your sum,
whether high frequency
or low frequency,
start from an angle
close to 0, and they
all drop from these
cosine of 0 equals 1.
And then as you
progress, when you
increase the distance
between positions, m and n,
you have your high
frequency cosine
terms that oscillate
between minus 1 and 1,
and they will tend to
cancel each other out.
So this is why you see some
oscillations but not that much.
And then later on you see more
and more oscillations coming in.
This is your low frequency
terms that start oscillating,
and this is how it
can be interpreted.
So why are we choosing
these positions embeddings
in the first place?
So we saw that we can have
an interesting interpretation
in terms of comparing two
position embeddings when
they are close versus
far from each other.
You have an intuitive
interpretation
as to the dot products that can
be compared to the distance.
And also something
that I haven't put here
and that was highlighted
by initial authors,
the position embedding when you
increase the position by a given
factor, k, can be represented
by a linear operation.
So when you have all these
matrix multiplication
operations, you can
see that operation
as being absorbed by
these matrix computations,
such that position information
can be taken into account.
So it has this linear
interpretation as well.
And the argument is that
it's very simple because you
have a pre-computed formula.
So let's say at
training time, you
have a given constraint
on the sequence length.
If at inference time you
change that parameter,
then you're not lost
because you know how
to extrapolate by the formula.
And so we see that it just
works well in practice.
But then on the flip side, and
I'm not talking about the fact
that it's hard-coded, but more
about the absolute property
of these position
embeddings, we saw
that it was introduced
at the input level,
whereas the initial
motivation where I mentioned
position embeddings
were helpful were more
at the attention level.
So it seems like we're injecting
this position information
at a place where that
information doesn't matter most,
but it might matter
most at places
where you want to
compare embeddings
with respect to one another.
So we're going to see
how to alleviate that.
And I mentioned as well this
extra interaction terms.
When you add position embeddings
at the very beginning,
that might interact with
the input embeddings.
And I'm not saying
this is bad, but I'm
saying this might not
be the intention we
have behind this
position embeddings.
So it doesn't seem to align
with the design choice
that we have in mind.
And just to give you some
information regarding who
used it, basically, everyone.
Like every first
paper on transformers
used absolute position
embedding-- so not necessarily
the hard-coded version, but the
one that adds it in the input.
So the transformer, of course,
did it the way I presented.
The original VIT
didn't hardcode it.
It was something
that was learned.
And then the DiT did hard-code
it but in 2D space in a manner
similar to one that we're
going to see very soon.
But it did so at
the input level.
Yeah.
A great point.
So what about the 2D case?
We're going to see it.
And yeah, great point.
But first before
doing that, we're
going to see if there
is a better location
to have these position
embeddings be represented.
And as you might have
guessed from all my hints,
the attention layer is going
to be the place to put them.
And this is the key insight from
RoPE Rotary Position Embeddings.
That was a paper in
2021 that introduced
these kinds of
representation of positions,
and that is the leading way
people do it in practice today.
And the way it
works is as follows.
You take queries.
You take keys.
And instead of fitting them
in the dot product as is,
you will rotate them by a
rotation operation that takes
into account their position.
So you take the query.
You rotate it with respect to
something that depends on m.
Same for key.
That depends on n, its position.
And you're going to do the dot
product of these rotated queries
and keys instead
of the raw ones.
And one nice property
that is interpretable
here is that you see
a rotation matrix that
depends on the difference of
positions, n minus m, pop out.
So you feel like it's a design
choice that that makes sense.
And then to answer your
points, now we're good for 1D.
But what about 2D?
So 2D you have this coordinates.
But if you don't talk
about coordinates just yet,
you might number
them in a 1D manner.
And it's not super clear whether
it makes sense at all to compare
1D numbers with
respect to one another.
So you have a few
ways to get around it.
So the first idea, which
is a similar flavor of what
the original DiT paper
used is to segregate axes,
such that you represent
vectors with respect
to their coordinates
in the 2D space.
And you do the x-axis in
some part of the vector
and the y-axis at
some other part.
And here we're talking
about one given
design choice of how to order
the indices with respect
to where you project.
But it doesn't have to be
grouped by even or odd indices.
You can group these
by any way you
want because this is arbitrary.
And so this is one
way of doing it.
It's called axial RoPE.
There is another way that
you could get around it
that mitigates the fact that--
so here if you do
the actual way,
one thing is that if you do
the dot product between two
rotated vectors, you realize
that you're comparing
x with x and y with y.
So you're missing that
interaction component.
And one way you can go around it
is to mix rotations with respect
to x and y in the same vector.
So this is the
so-called mixed RoPE.
And the authors of the paper
that discuss these two 2D
strategies made a representation
of a given input position
and applied a frequency-based
technique that I know some
of you might know from the
physics space called the Fourier
Transform.
So to apply the
Fourier Transform,
it's filtered out for a
given frequency's budget--
only those that were
taken into consideration.
And after trying to
reconstruct the signal
from these set of
frequencies, saw
that Axial RoPE had all
these axial artifacts that
were due to this lack of
interaction between the two
axes, whereas Mixed RoPE
was able to leverage
the same set of frequencies,
like the same set
of frequencies budgets in
a way more efficient way.
So these are two ways
of looking at them,
and mixing things seems
to make it better.
And something else that you
might worry about beyond taking
into account the 2D case, is how
to make sense of these positions
when you have different number
of patches presented to you.
So, for example, let's
say your teddy bear
is in low resolution
versus high resolution.
How does it make
sense me as a model
to interpret what is at the
center of the image versus what
is on the left or
what is on the right?
And this is what
Seedream 2 thought about.
And the idea here is to
center the coordinates
in a way that will
tell the model where
the center of the image is
in order for it to locate
different parts of the image.
So instead of having like
a grid that starts from 0,
you have the 0 roughly being
at the center of the image,
and then you adjust
the external points.
And one thing that you might
wonder by Afshine's description
of MM-DiT models,
for example, those
that perform joint
attention, so you
have these points
in the architecture
where you might have text tokens
interacting with image tokens.
So one question you
might ask yourself,
how to quantify the position of
one with respect to the other.
And by thinking
about this, one thing
you might want to think
about is what wouldn't work.
So what wouldn't
work intuitively
is the positions at the
horizontal lines of the image
and the vertical ones.
Because intuitively, you
do not want your model
to think that your
text tokens are
a continuation of your image.
So one natural position that
the coin image paper points out
is the diagonal, because
it's clear that it's out
of the area of the image.
And by doing so, they see that
they can just live together.
And if you use an actual
formulation of the 2D
representation, you even notice
that your text tokens become
equivalent to the 1D case
because you have your x
and y's that are incremented
by 1 between one another.
So just you fall back
on the same case.
And so I just went through
some of the keys that made some
of these techniques work well.
I just want to say that this
is very much an open problem.
There is no many papers that use
the same techniques but rather
many that use variations to
reach their own architectures,
goals.
And then there are
trade offs as well.
And you might remember
from the early slides
that we were talking about teddy
bear that was wanting to dance.
So here is our teddy bear
wishing you a great weekend.